THE FDA.
IF APPROVED IT WILL BECOME THE
FIRST AVAILABLE TO PROTECT
BABIES AGAINST RSV.
JOHN?
>>> SO THIS MORNING WE ARE
GETTING A MUCH CLEARER PICTURE
OF HOW FLORIDA GOVERNOR RON
DeSANTIS PLANS TO POSITION
HIMSELF AS A PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE.
THE OFFICIAL ANNOUNCEMENT COMING
NEXT WEEK, BUT HE LAID OUT THESE
PLANS IN A CONFERENCE CALL WITH
BIG DONORS.
WE WILL HAVE MUCH MORE ON THAT
IN A SECOND, BUT THERE IS ALSO
THIS NEW DEVELOPMENT THAT PLAYS
INTO ALL OF THIS.
HIS FEUD WITH DISNEY, THE HUGE
ENTERTAINMENT COMPANY AND MAJOR
FLORIDA EMPLOYER ANNOUNCED THAT
IT IS CANCELING PLANS, THEY DID
THIS YESTERDAY AFTERNOON, TO
BUILD A NEW $1 BILLION OFFICE
CAMPUS IN THE GREATER ORLANDO
AREA.
DISNEY CITED CHANGING BUSINESS
CONDITIONS AS THE REASON FOR NOT
MOVING FORWARD.
CNN'S NATASHA CHEN HAS MORE ON
ALL OF THIS.
THIS IS, WHAT, LIKE 2,000 JOBS?
>> YEAH, JOHN, 2,000 JOBS.
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE A REGIONAL
HUB FOR PARKS AND RESORTS SO
SOME OF THE IMAGINEERS THAT
DESIGN ALL THE STUFF YOU SEE IN
THE THEME PARKS, AS WELL AS SOME
CORPORATE JOBS, CONSUMER
PRODUCT, SUPPORT FUNCTIONS LIKE
FINANCE TECHNOLOGY, MARKETING,
COMMUNICATIONS, THIS WAS GOING
TO BE AT A COMPLEX IN LAKE NONA
THAT DISNEY PURCHASED, JUST EAST
OF WALT DISNEY WORLD IN CENTRAL
FLORIDA AND THE MOVE WAS GOING
TO TAKE OVER THE COURSE OF
SEVERAL YEARS AND THE COMPANY
WAS GIVING PEOPLE SOME
FLEXIBILITY ABOUT THIS.
I'M NOW HEARING THAT SOME PEOPLE
WHO DID NOT WANT TO MOVE TO
FLORIDA ACTUALLY LEFT THE
COMPANY AND FOUND OTHER JOBS TO
AVOID THAT MOVE AND NOW IT'S NOT
HAPPENING AT ALL.
ABOUT 200 PEOPLE ALREADY DID
MAKE THAT MOVE AND SO YESTERDAY
IN A MEMO THE CHAIRMAN OF DISNEY
PARKS, EXPERIENCES AND PRODUCTS
SAYS THEY WILL WORK WITH THOSE
INDIVIDUALS INCLUDING THE
POSSIBILITY OF MOVING THEM BACK
HERE TO BURBANK IN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AREA.
NOW, AS FAR AS REACTION GOES,
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS DID
RELEASE A STATEMENT THROUGH HIS
SPOKESPERSON AND I WANT TO READ
THAT TO YOU, THIS WAS ACQUIRED
BY STEVE CONTORNO.
HE DID SAY IT WAS UNSURPRISING
THAT DISNEY WOULD CANCEL THE
PROJECT GIVEN THE COMPANY'S
FINANCIAL STRAITS, FALLING
MARKET CAP AND DECLINING STOCK
PRICE.
UNSURPRISING THEY WOULD
RESTRUCTURE THEIR BUSINESS
OPERATIONS AND CANCEL
UNSUCCESSFUL VENTURES.
WHEN WE DID HEAR FROM OTHER
LOCAL LEADERS AS WELL, ORANGE
COUNTY MAYOR DEMINGS AND THE
FLORIDA DEMOCRATIC PARTY CHAIR
ALL SAYING THAT THIS IS REALLY
BECAUSE OF THE DeSANTIS/DISNEY
FEUD THAT THEY FEEL THAT THEY'VE
LOST THESE FLORIDA JOBS.
IN THE MEANTIME THE TRUMP WAR
ROOM OFFICIAL CAMPAIGN ACCOUNT
ON TWITTER ALSO PUT UP THIS
TWEET YESTERDAY QUOTING THE
STORY SAYING RON DeSANCTIMONIOUS
GETS CAUGHT IN THE MOUSE TRAP,
THE CULTURE OF LOSING CONTINUES.
SO THIS REALLY PLAYED INTO THE
POLITICS OF THE MOMENT AND OF
COURSE A LOT OF BUSINESS
DECISIONS WENT INTO THIS AS FAR
AS WHAT MADE SENSE FOR THE
COMPANY, BUT YOU CAN'T HELP BUT
SEE THIS IN THE GREATER CONTEXT
AS WELL OF WHETHER THEY WILL
THRIVE AS A BUSINESS AS THEY ARE
HAVING THIS FEUD WITH THE
GOVERNOR OF THE STATE.
JOHN?
>> ALL RIGHT.
NATASHA CHEN FOR YOU, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
AS WE SAID, THIS IS PART OF A
MUCH BIGGER MOMENT FOR RON
DeSANTIS AND THE NEW
DEVELOPMENTS ARE LAST NIGHT HE
LAID OUT HIS VISION OF A
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN TO MAJOR
DONORS.
WITH US NOW FROM FLORIDA, CNN'S
STEVE CONTORNO.
I'VE BEEN ON CONFERENCE CALLS
WITH CAMPAIGN STRATEGISTS THAT
SOUNDED LIKE WHAT RON DeSANTIS
DID LAST NIGHT, WHERE HE LAID
OUT HIS CASE FOR HOW HE'S GOING
TO WIN AND HE SORT OF MADE IT
ALL ABOUT ELECTABILITY.
>> Reporter: THAT'S RIGHT, JOHN.
WE KNOW THAT DeSANTIS HAS BEEN
MEETING WITH DONORS FOR SEVERAL
WEEKS NOW LEADING UP TO THIS
EXPECTED LAUNCH.
ONE OF THE REASONS HE HAS BEEN
MEETING WITH THEM IS TO SHORE UP
THEIR SUPPORT BECAUSE A LOT ARE
CONCERNED WITH SOME OF HIS
RECENT MOMS AND RECENT STUMBLES.
THERE ARE REPUBLICAN DONORS WHO
OBJECT TO THE FACT THAT THE
STATE SIGNED THIS SIX-WEEK
ABORTION BAN, THEY'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT HIS WAFFLING ON WHETHER HE
WOULD SUPPORT UKRAINE AND
WHETHER THIS RUSSIA IS RIGHT IN
THIS WAR.
SO HE HAS TAKEN A MORE DIRECT
ROLE IN ASSURING THESE DONORS
THAT HE HAS A STRATEGY TO BEAT
TRUMP AND THAT STRATEGY IS TO
SAY, LOOK, I AM MUCH MORE A
ELECTABLE, ESPECIALLY IN THE
STATES THAT ARE GOING TO MATTER
IN THE PRESIDENTIAL CONTEST
AGAINST JOE BIDEN.
LISTEN TO WHAT HE TOLD THOSE
DONORS ACCORDING TO THE "NEW
YORK TIMES."
HE SAID, YOU HAVE BASICALLY
THREE PEOPLE AT THIS POINT THAT
ARE CREDIBLE IN THIS WHOLE
THING, BIDEN, TRUMP AND ME.
TWO HAVE A CHANCE TO GET ELECTED
PRESIDENT, BIDEN AND ME BASED ON
ALL THE DATA IN THE SPRING
STATES.
SO NOT ONLY IS HE CLEARLY
SAYING, LOOK, IT'S BETWEEN ME,
TRUMP AND BIDEN IN A WAY THAT
JUST TOTALLY DISMISSES THE OTHER
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES IN THE
FIELD, BUT HE'S SAYING TRUMP
CAN'T GET ELECTED AND THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY SURPRISING TO HEAR
THAT FROM A CANDIDATE WHO IS
TRYING TO CURRY SUPPORT, BUT
DeSANTIS HAS REALLY AVOIDED
GOING DIRECTLY AT TRUMP
THROUGHOUT MOST OF THIS RUN UP
TO HIS CAMPAIGN AND YET HERE HE
IS IN VERY STARK TERMS SAYING,
LOOK, THIS GUY CAN'T GET ELECTED
AGAIN, I'M YOUR BEST BET IF YOU
WANT TO GET A REPUBLICAN IN THE
WHITE HOUSE IN 2024.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, IT'S VERY BLUNT
LANGUAGE, EVEN MORE INTERESTING
COMING FROM THE CANDIDATE
HIMSELF, NOT A STRATEGIST THERE.
SO, STEVE, WHERE DOES THIS WHOLE
DISNEY THING FIT INTO IT WITH
DISNEY MAKING THIS ANNOUNCEMENT
JUST DAYS BEFORE RON DeSANTIS IS
GOING TO MAKE IT OFFICIAL THAT
HE'S RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT?
>> Reporter: WELL, IT'S JUST
ANOTHER SIGN THAT THIS BACK AND
FORTH BETWEEN DISNEY AND
DeSANTIS ISN'T GOING AWAY.
IT'S BEEN SUCH A HUGE PART OF
HIS NARRATIVE AND ON HIS TERMS,
HE WANTS TO TALK ABOUT DISNEY.
HE MADE IT A WHOLE CHAPTER IN
HIS BOOK, FREQUENTLY DISCUSSES
IT ON THE TRAIL WHEN IN
POLITICAL EVENTS IN IOWA AND NEW
HAMPSHIRE AND ALL THESE OTHER
STATES, BUT DISNEY CONTINUES TO
PUNCH BACK IN A WAY THAT PUT
THIS IN A NEGATIVE LIGHT FOR
DeSANTIS, JUST AS THEY DID WHEN
THEY OUTMANEUVERED HIM EARLIER
THIS SPRING AND SUGGESTING THAT
THEY ARE GOING TO CUT 2,000
HIGH-PAYING JOBS FROM THE STATE
REALLY IS GIVING HIS OPPONENTS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DING HIM AS
ANTI-BUSINESS AS HE PREPARES TO
ENTER THIS PRIMARY, JOHN.